No.
There's this idea in very deep
idea and clinical psychology,
a fundamental idea,
which is that if someone's
anxious about something,
what you do is you,
and it's getting in their way.
You take what they're anxious about,
new,
define it cause that already d limits it,
right?
Because one of the problems with being
anxious about something as you won't
speak of it,
it's like Voldemort.
And then if you don't speak of it,
it's way bigger than it should be.
As soon as you start talking about it,
you cut it down to size.
And so,
and it,
it's for a bunch of reasons.
It's because you're not as,
you're not as afraid of as many things
as you think and you're braver than you
know,
and more and more capable.
So as soon as you're brave enough to
start talking about what you're afraid of,
then you see that there's more to you
than you thought and that there's less to
the problem than you thought.
And then you can decompose it further
into smaller problems and then you can
figure out how to approach
those smaller problems.
And so,
and then it doesn't seem to meet
to be that you get less frightened.
It seems to be that you
get more courageous,
which is way better than
being less frightened because
there's lots of things to
be frightened about.
So if you're courageous that
that really does the trick.
Now the question is what
happens if you like,
let's say that you're a very socially
inept and you don't know how to introduce
yourself or to make any established
the initial parts of relationship with
anyone.
And so then you start putting yourself
in situations where you're required to do
that.
And so then the question is,
how is it technically that you transform?
You say,
well,
you learn well,
we want to be more specific about that.
What does it mean that you learn?
Well,
if you're dealing with someone who's
particularly socially inept and you're
doing psychotherapy with them,
you might teach them how to
shake someone's hand properly
and say their name and
remember the other person's name.
So you just practice that with them so
that they have the motoric routine down.
So that form of knowledge is
built right into your body.
It's like,
look at the person,
put out your hand,
shake it.
Don't not like a dead Halibut,
but you know with a reasonable grip,
say your name,
don't mumble it.
Look,
look at them so that they can hear you.
And then when they say their name,
tried to remember it,
and that's men.
So you can practice that with people.
And so then they develop
something that's motoric,
right?
It's embedded right in their body.
And so,
and then you can say to them,
well the other thing you can do is when
you start a conversation is don't sit
there thinking about what
you're going to say next.
Because then you won't be paying attention
to the person and you'll make a fool
out of yourself because
you'll manifest nonsequitors.
Right?
Because you'll get out of,
it's like if you're dancing and all
you're paying attention to is where your
feet are,
then you're going to step on
the other person all the time.
So you want to pay attention to the other
person and then whatever automatized
social knowledge you have
will come to the forefront.
So it's a good thing to know
if you're socially anxious,
right?
If you're socially anxious,
one of the things you should do is pay
way more to the person you're talking to
rather than less.
And you should pay as little
attention as possible to yourself.
So if you feel yourself falling
in because you're anxious,
then what you do is you
push your attention out and
pay attention to the person
because to the degree that
you've been socialized,
then all your automatic
responses will kick in.
So,
but anyway,
so you go out into the social world and
you learn to shake someone's hand and
you learn how to listen to them and ask
them questions because that's the next
thing.
Because people love,
you can't just ask them random questions,
obviously.
But if they start talking to you and you
don't understand something about what
they're saying or maybe something they
said is interesting and you ask them a
question,
they're pretty damn happy about that
because it means you're actually paying
attention to them and people actually
love to be paid attention to because it
hardly ever happens.
So they really,
really like it.
And so,
okay,
so,
so what's happening?
Well first of all,
you're mastering the
automated motor movements,
right?
Where to point your eyes,
where to put your hands,
how to move your lips,
like really embodied knowledge.
It's a special kind of memory
and you're practicing that.
And so that's building new skills for you.
And then by listening to the person
and watching yourself interact,
you're also generating new,
new abstract information that enables
you to conceptualize the world in a
different way.
So if you go out to 10 you go out
and talk to 10 different people or 50
different people,
then you get to listen to
what those 50 people said.
You get to watch how they're,
how they express themselves and
you gather a corpus of knowledge,
the changes,
the way you perceive that
broadens you as a social agent.
Okay.
So that's two forms of knowledge.
But then there's a third one
which is really interesting,
which is that you know,
you have a lot of biological potential
and it's hard to know what potentially
is,
but part of it is that you're capable
of generating proteins that you haven't
been generating.
So you should get right
on that by the way.
So,
but what the way that works in part is
that if you put yourself in a radically
new situation,
then your brain that,
that there are genetic switches that
turn on because of the demands of the new
situation,
that code for new proteins.
So it's as if you have latent software.
That would be one way of thinking about
that will only be turned on if you go
into the situation where that's necessary.
And so then you might think,
well,
if that's the case,
how much have you could be turned on
if you went a whole bunch of different
places.
And that's a really,
really,
that's a profound question because one
of the deep answers to how you should get
your life together is you should go a
very large number of places and turn
yourself on.